Chuck Startalk is closing in on 1
million subscribers that's right that's
right well you you may be our one
millionth customer
we are planning a special event when
that happens that's right we're gonna do
a live cosmic queries so the deal is you
can actually be with us and instead of
me butchering your name you can say your
name to Neil and then ask him a question
it's gonna be really cool so you got to
make sure that you hit subscribe if
you're not a subscriber and turn on your
notifications so that you can know
exactly when this event is gonna happen
and you won't miss out all right we'll
see you then
hey there Neil hey Matt Pat thanks for
dropping in on Startalk
hey Matt Pat how are you buddy so I get
a lot of requests to cover theories on
the show Rick and Morty and I was hoping
that you guys might be able to help me
out with some of the science elements so
in season 1 episode 4 we learned that
one of the things that put Rick on the
multiversal most-wanted list
is his ability to harness the energy
that's found inside of dark Manor and in
that episode we actually learned that
his spaceship runs on a fuel made of
concentrated dark matter and it's not
like this is a new concept right science
fiction has been talking about dark
matter for decades at this point and in
the latent potential found inside of it
but I was wondering what is dark matter
in the first place is it as powerful as
science fiction leads us to believe
could it power a spaceship like the one
that we see in Rick and Morty and most
importantly of all can it be our
gasoline in the future I want to know
you want to know whether is the new form
of gasoline for getting around the
galaxy is there anything which by the
way if you look at Rick's Rick and Morty
if you look at his ship the engines are
made out of garbage cans but it's okay
because genius
that's how they cover that right well so
my first comment is try to not get your
science from cartoons that's just a just
to just start there
some a few decades ago this how old this
is someone compiled a list of the
cartoon laws of physics have you seen
this jack
no I haven't yes yeah yeah yeah Matt I
don't know if you've seen it but this so
the first one is when you run off of a
cliff gravity only engages after you
notice you have run off of the cliff you
don't just fall you have to fight hover
there look around realize there's no
longer ground beneath you and then you
fall so that's a that's a law of physics
manifested in cartoons for example so
there's a you're a coyote yeah I don't
know if it's species dependent but
definitely the best examples are from
the coyote so but we can make an
exception here with Rick and Morty
because there's clearly a lot of thought
put into the science that's in it and
the implications of the science that's
in it timelines and and and bio genetic
transformations so Rick and Morty has
elevated itself to be worthy of this
kind of discussion I just want to say
that that's what happens Morty that's my
trick it's awful I'll give it a that's a
b-plus okay so here's the thing probably
they had intended to say dark energy
instead of dark matter probably the
reason why I the reason why I offer this
is that dark energy is a mysterious by
the way they're both mysterious we don't
know what either of them are made of
dark matter or dark energy dark matter
is a source of gravity in the universe
it's most of the ground
he manifested in the universe is from
this mysterious entity called dark
matter dark energy is a mysterious
pressure in the vacuum of space that is
causing matter to to accelerate away
from itself and so the expanding
universe is accelerating against the
interests and the wishes of the
collective gravity of all the galaxies
so people who have wondering whether
this can be tapped as an energy source
they're generally they apply that to
dark energy because then if you're over
here and you want to be over there you
put in the the negative gravity and you
then you just shoot away from whatever
would have been pulling you in in the
first place so but that being said if
you want to stick to the script and the
dark matter concept it turns out dark
matter does not interact with our matter
at all other than by its gravity and
what I mean by that is if you have a
like a cup of water and you grab it you
can touch the glass at this water inside
that doesn't spill out of the glass you
can interact with the atoms and
molecules of our world
Dark Matter does not interact that way
in fact if there is something made of
dark matter in front of you you would
not be able to see it you would not even
be able to touch it because the forces
involved with dark matter are not the
same as the forces involved in the
molecules of your flesh but there's an
additional problem dark matter not only
doesn't interact with our molecules it
doesn't interact with itself if it
doesn't interact with itself it can't
concentrate itself it can't latch on to
itself so our best current ideas of dark
matter tell us there is no dark matter
thing out there you can't concentrate
dark matter because that implies you can
get it to stick together to itself so
but again it's science fiction and it's
a cartoon so we give it to him what
they've done there
the writers is taken something that's
mysterious still mysterious on the
frontier physics and made something fun
with it in the cartoon and fine may be
the day we discover what dark matter is
and dark energy maybe you could do all
of that then what what Rick is doing
with those garbage cans in a spaceship I
can't say no technically okay but that's
the fun part of good science fiction
that you keep what you know intact and
take the stuff that's on the boundary
and extend that into the storytelling
that you care about so two things I take
away from this one is that dark matter
is a bit of an a-hole very antisocial
just you know it doesn't want to be
bothered with anyone or anything and -
this is what we're hearing from Tyson C
138 in this dimension but in is there
another dimension where like Tyson 365
might have another explanation
no all Tyson's are coordinated the
Citadel of Tyson through the Citadel
we're all trained in the same school
yeah so - you can't ask what it is that
he's using we can say sure they're safe
in the realm of our modern day
scientific ignorance and he's a genius
so there it is there you go thank you
that actually answers my question really
well but well I have you here and while
we're talking about matter I'd love to
ask one more in the episode more tonight
run we're introduced to a character
named fart it's this a cloud that's able
to change the composition of atoms now
in the episode we're specifically told
that fart can't be destroyed using
regular matter that instead he needs to
be killed using an antimatter gun now
the question is what is antimatter is
that just a scientific hypothetical or
is it a real thing and if it is real
what is its theoretical you see
outside of you know killing cloud-based
life-forms oh god I love it by the way
probably one of my favorite episodes of
Rick and Morty ever because of fart and
they do kind of like a little David but
we asked a musical number a called
goodbye moon men and I don't know it's
sublime to me I just thought and by the
way
fart a Rick named some fart because
because he's gaseous of course he
doesn't have form and so and he doesn't
know what a fart is and so he says I
like this name fart so it's not a it's
not an acronym for something you know I
haven't seen that episode that's not but
I can totally talk about antimatter so
first of all antimatter is real this
favorite fuel of science fiction it is
real it was proposed back in the 1930s
and it would take a while before it was
discovered in the laboratory and it
turns out that for all the ordinary
particles that we know and love there is
a version of that particle that is
identical to it in all ways except
certain key properties which when they
come back together with its original
with the matter particle they annihilate
entirely so you start with two particles
they get together and poof they simply
become energy it's a perfect
annihilation
it's matter and antimatter so it's the
great term antimatter it's like the
force and the dark side you know the two
sides of a coin it's so that's why plays
so well into science fiction and into
storytelling and so we happen to live in
a universe filled with matter but we can
make antimatter in the laboratory all
right so now you have mater and you want
to destroy it generally if you're the
military and you want to destroy
something you break it apart so that
what
so however it used to function it no
longer functions that way all right
but if you have a substance that doesn't
depend on whether it's attached in a
particular way that it's that it's very
essence is just the matter that it is
then hacking away bits of it is not
going to make a difference think of in
Terminator 2 the the liquid metal
Terminator you can break pieces apart
from him and he still has the essence of
what he is as that as that model there
was at the T 2000 or something yeah I
forgot so it turns out if you have this
cloud of atoms no you're not going to
destroy them because it's matter unless
you figure out a way to turn it entirely
into energy so now you get an antimatter
particle stream to shoot into this
madness fart matter
and then you can't annihilate the fart
matter with anti fart matter and then it
becomes pure energy and whatever the
thing was before it is no longer so so
by the way the movie which was at one of
the Dan Brown movies angels and demons I
think that was the one of course the
story too but I tend to watch movies
rather than read the books so I'm
referencing the movie forgive me you
literate folks out there so in there the
Vatican is walking around with this vial
of antimatter and it's carried around
like it's something precious and it
could destabilize the world so first
I've been in some church basements I've
never seen particle accelerators there
so I don't know how they came up with
antimatter not going to the right Church
[Laughter]
it must be well church basements I've
been into it the cupcakes and bake sales
that's all I saw on motivations
we have the particle daemon out the
demons have been removed right I cast
you out boson Beelzebub zombie go so
boson is an actual particle to chuck you
doing your homework on this so here's my
point
they they're walking around like it's
something rare and precious but we can
manufacture antimatter all the time and
on command in particle accelerators so
it sounded good in the fictional
storytelling but in practice it's really
bad science fiction in that sense
because it's not something weird or
exotic but it does have the power to
annihilate and as it has it's the most
efficient way to turn matter into energy
the Sun turns matter into energy all the
time by converting hydrogen into helium
but that's not as efficient as turning
pure matter and antimatter into pure
energy so there you have it the fart gas
and fire the a a prop a an effective
countermeasure to the fart gas yes yes
antimatter fart gets believe me I've had
a couple cases of that so it's it's not
as much science fiction this people
might think so what you don't want is
and find your twin in an antimatter
universe who's also gassy that could
that could destabilize all the creation
in every other unit sooo that's all the
time we have for today but make sure you
check out where I would say called
filmed theorists Channel great name this
is like people thinking about films in
ways and dimensions that I bet the
director and producers had never
intended
and on there I will discuss theories of
the multiverse and one of the Rick and
Morty episodes involving dark matter and
we do that with of course mat pad so I
by the way will put that specific link
in the description anyway thanks for
your questions Matt Pat you got it Thank
You Neil and Chuck we're hoping to
formulate these theories with me no
problem and thanks Chuck as always for
helping me decode the universe for
anyone who will listen my pleasure
always
and until next time as always keep
looking up Chuck I got a package in the
mail look at that it's a black box did
you go to our crash site go to a crash
site and pick up some black from YouTube
it could be our million subscriber
plaque it could open it oh no no you
can't open it we have to open that live
on the air during the event I won't open
it now now you the kid that's found the
presents in the closet five days before
Christmas and you got to wait till
Christmas Day now man that is punishment
so there you go if you want to see
what's in the box just make sure you
subscribe and turning you notifications
and you can see at the live of it I also
want to see what's in the box okay
alright we'll see you guys there and
you